[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur figaro live
on est content de vous retrouver vous
êtes en direct dans les studios du
figaro et on attend vos points de vue
notamment sur les mesures qu'on annonce
celle dont tout le monde parle et qu'on
ne connaît pas encore en tout cas on
spécule dessus en un mot faut-il
reconfirmer faut-il reconfirmer juste
localement faut-il étendre le couvre-feu
faut-il garder les écoles ouvertes si on
confine ça c'est la question qu'on pose
sur le site du figaro et le figaro qui
revient dans les prochaines heures bien
sûr largement sur ces mesures nouvelles
qui doivent être annoncés je parle sous
le contrôle d'alexis braisé le directeur
des rédactions qui est ici ce soir
bonsoir avec 6% et face à vous avec nous
un philippe meyer bonsoir philippe
animateurs du sur son frère cadet sa
chair et un confrère je dis nouvelle
république
podcast à retrouver sur le site du même
nom le nouvel esprit public.fr c'est
magique vous allez l'avoir tout de suite
dans le tchat
l'autre débat ce soir qu'on vous propose
et sur cette étude concerne cette étude
récente de la faune d'apple a que vous
pouvez retrouver sur le site du figaro
sur laquelle près de 80% des français
79% très exactement sont prêts à bouder
les urnes ou à voter pour un candidat
type le pen ou mélenchon à la prochaine
élection présidentielle est ce votre cas
y croyez vous le vous en réjouissez vous
le déplorez vous en tous les cas on en
débat mais d'abord une question auquel
sera quelles seront les décisions prises
par emmanuel macron et le gouvernement
on vous le révèle depuis 24 heures trois
scénarios sont sur la table
première piste l'extension du couvre-feu
des dix neuf heures et le week-end
deuxième piste 1re confinement locales
et puis une autre piste 1re confinement
général cette piste là peut y croire
mais certains le souhaitent notamment le
professeur gilles pialoux chef de
service à l'hôpital tenon à paris pense
qu'il faut confier clairement le pays
faut il faut laisser de côté l'économie
l'économie c'est rattrapable de
rattrapage la ranimation louper c'est
pas rattrapable et je pense qu'il faut
en appeler aussi à la responsabilité
citoyenne c1
c'est un élément important il faut que
une cohésion sociale il faut arrêter les
débats contradictoires
al'inverse bien on est encore dans les
débats contradictoires d'autres refusent
cette perspective je vous propose
d'écouter d'abord jordan bardella pour
le rassemblement national puis laurent
berger pour la cfdt
leur confinement devra être l'ultime
recours
je pense que le gouvernement devrait
d'abord se regarder dans un miroir parce
que le confinement serait la réponse de
ceux qui ont tout raté de ceux qui n'ont
pas anticipé dans la question de
sanitaires c'est par une organisation
syndicale en tout cas la cfdt qui peut
dire ce qu'il faut faire
je crois qu'il faut que chacun joue son
rôle moi ce que je vais vous dire ce que
je vais lui dire c'est que dans cette
période là il faut protéger aussi les
travailleurs avec 6 il ya quinze jours
on ne croyait pas trop au couvre-feu
puis il ya eu le couvre-feu là ma
question c'est est ce qu'il faut garder
tout de suite l'idée d'un confinement
général sachant que selon notre consoeur
à 21,0 du service politique du figaro
1re confinement sur l'ensemble du
territoire n'est pas exclue d'après une
confidence d'un député qui était présent
au déjeuner de la majorité
puis en gros nos trains discuter de
l'ampleur de la punition je souhaiterais
qu'on puisse écarter l'hypothèse du
confinement total je crains qu'on ne
puisse pas les garder a alors offert un
dommage parce que tous à ce débat en ce
moment ma croûte en avoir tout un tas de
monde mais de autant hier on disait non
on va trouver quelque chose qui va
ressembler quand même étrangement au
confinement mais avec un certain nombre
de différences et notamment le fait que
selon les endroits ce serait pas pareil
là on a le sentiment depuis le début
d'après midi mais je ça peut changer je
l'espère que tout le monde doit être
logé mais l'ancien décombres on
reviendrait à epsilon près s'ils ont un
peu plus que pilote qui serait peut-être
les écoles pour les enfants ne
reviendraient au confinement de du mois
de mars
philips sur twitter une experte de la
com politique voit dans les différentes
rumeurs défense annonce
piste lancé une stratégie de
communication pour faire éclater
l'opinion à des mesures de durcissement
ça vous paraît juste écoutez c'est drôle
parce que ça rejoint une remarque que
j'allais faire quelques il me semble que
pour que les mesures qui vont être
prises est un peu plus d'effet elles
doivent être inattendu elle lave pas
être précédée au contraire de tellement
de fuite que finalement nous avons
l'impression peut-être à tort que nous
pourrions aujourd'hui vous dire ce que
le président de la république va dire
demain à quelques petits détails près
mais alexis a mentionné les écoles etc
donc il ya quelque chose qui s'effiloche
complètement dans cette communication et
ça me paraît contreproductif
après l'idée que alors c'est un nouveau
complot c'est ça c'est un fait le jeu ne
sais quel spécialiste de la
communication qui est aux côtés du
président de la république le dit il
faut distiller un petit peu pour que je
ne crois pas un mot
l'expérience m'a appris et sa
connectique quant à l'excès c'est très
malin ils ont fait ça parce que parce
que parce que parce que non simplement
et je me suis tu parce qu'elle fuite
parce que rien est étanche qu' il ya des
journées ce qui se passe des coups de
fil des gars qui veulent se faire
mousser et mais l'idée de la fuite
génial qui va tester l'opinion je n'y ai
jamais cru dans aucun domaine bon
parfait heureux de mandela aux
internautes ce qu'ils en pensent
christophe new deal confinement ne sert
à rien les animations seront débordés
tôt ou tard et babineau qui pensent
qu'avec l'échec de la stratégie
nationale de dépistage le gouvernement
n'a plus d'autre choix que de re confiné
l'appropriation alors ça sur save au
point de vue justement si moi je crois
que le confinement toujours un échec
c'est quand même un truc plus moyenne un
jeu qui soit ces deux guides et dont on
va sauver les gens en les enfermant à
double tour chez eux donc il ya pas plus
rustique et simpliste comme méthode
parfois on y conduit est parfois y'a pas
le choix c'est parfois un mal nécessaire
mais c'est mal disait lui-même la
sanction d'un échec c'est parce qu'elles
sont deux choses n'ont pas marché
tout à coup on a obligés d'enfermer les
gens chez eux là en l'occurrence ce qui
n'a pas marché je parle plus des masques
on a tellement parlé mais ça depuis
maintenant il semblerait qu'on en ait au
moins c'est déjà ça non
ce qui n'a évidemment pas marché c'est
tout ce triptyque tester isolé d'être
assez isolé
enfin les tests n'ont pas marché
absolument pas or c'était les moyens de
contenir l'épidémie
avant ça et c'est un échec on reparlera
peut-être aussi des tests des tests
antigénique parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on s'obstine dans l'échec mais ça
c'est une autre histoire
donc en amont il ya un échec et en aval
il ya un échec qui suit de la taille des
hopis des lits de réanimation et du
personnel fait pour les servir de vidéos
si on avait aujourd'hui plus de lits en
réanimation ou en urgence avec plus de
gens pour servir ces lits on serait
moins embêtés pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
obligé de tout bloquer parce qu'on se
dit ça va être engorgé il y en aurait
plus ça serait engrangé moins vite ça
veut pas dire que ça ne serait pas mais
tout semaine gagnez tout en gagner est
très important
quand le médecin ne leur disais c'est
rattrapable l'économie non non il ya des
dégâts qui sont plus rattrapable
quand les boîtes ont fait faillite quand
les jeunes quand les gars sont ruinés
quand lisent les gens perdu leur emploi
les conséquences sur leur santé sur la
psychologie sur leur bonheur sur tout ça
c'est pas rattrapable c'est pas de la
rigolade non plus l'économie un
saucisson la vie politique qui sont
forcément très importants passés à
l'annulation des régionales par exemple
ou et ça encore honnêtement ça ne me
fait pas une douleur considérable
l'annulation des régionales ce que je
pense par contre c'est que dans une
situation dans laquelle beaucoup de gens
ont le sentiment que le gouvernement ne
tient pas les choses et dans laquelle
voit arriver cet ultime solution qui est
celle du confinement il peut y avoir une
attitude politique qui renforce la
tendance dont nous allons parler tout à
l'heure c'est à dire celle qui pousse
les gens vers l'abstention ou vert vers
un vote extrémiste populiste c'est une
autre juste à propos du confinement a
ajouté une question le premier
confinement a été très respectée il a
été très respecté il me semble
à quelques exceptions près j'en ai vu à
paris je pense à
une espèce de rue sacré qu'est le la rue
que bertrand delanoë mais a montré à
tous les visiteurs illustres que la rue
montorgueil ou là ont effectivement
pendant le premier conflit non j'ai vu
une débauche d'insouciance pour utiliser
un terme poli tout à fait étonnant mais
d'une manière générale sur le à paris et
dans les grandes villes et sur
l'ensemble du territoire
le confinement a été respectée depuis je
suis pas très sûr que les mentalités
n'ai pas changé et que on peut lire sur
instagram par exemple tout un tas de
recettes pour échapper au couvre-feu
je ne suis pas sûr qu' il n'y ait pas
une espèce de de lassitude de
l'exaltation d'une forme
d'individualisme enfin appelez ça comme
vous voulez trouver lui toutes les
raisons possibles
je ne suis pas sûr qu'un deuxième
confinement serait respectée j'allais
dire aussi spontanément ce qui voudrait
dire qu'il faudrait encore plus de
police on n'a guère plus de police qu'on
a plus d'infirmiers de personnel
soignant de médecins et de l'hydra
animations de surcroît le personnel de
police il vaudrait mieux qu'ils puissent
être occupés à des tâches de lutte
contre les le terrorisme les attentats
plutôt que courir derrière ceux qui
veulent le pouvoir circuler n'importe
quand n'importe comment
donc là je pense qu'on va affronter une
difficulté supplémentaire
je crois que si on regarde les études
d'opinion on se rend compte que
l'adhésion quasi totale qui avait à six
mois n'est plus de mise que on le voyait
dès qu'ils avaient une question d'un
sondage où nous dans le questionnaire
qu'on fait en ligne au figaro décomposer
une question sur faut-il prendre telle
ou telle précaution c'était toujours oui
à 85 90 % donc ça a beaucoup baissé
le de vous citiez le sondage a faut-il
un nouveau contrat pas le sondage le
questionnaire qu'on fait en ligne
au fait la com de 70000 réponse un c'est
quand même énorme où est donc je dis
dans mon souvenir c'est 60% des gens qui
répondent non
1 la faute hilare confinement tout il
reconnaît que ce sera fait en ligne
sociaux donc tout ça pour dire que je ne
crois pas qu une fois que ce sera décidé
de sa sera pas 60% dont certains
semblent 60% de oui mais 60% de oui
c'est 40% de non et donc c'est vrai que
là là les français rod et comme
extrêmement discipliné je ne crois pas
moi je crois pas à un phénomène de
révolte je crois effectivement à des
phénomènes de 2,2 système des deux
systèmes d'e on ruse et dida et
peut-être après un phénomène en revanche
de de revanche politique de punition
politique
ensuite parce que les gens diront toi tu
nous enfermer deux fois de suite parce
que ce que pensent comme les gens c'est
qu'on nous enfermer la première fois bon
on n'était pas prêts ok mais peut-être
qu entre la première fois la deuxième on
aurait pu se préparer ensemble de choses
le sentiment des uns des autres c'est
quand même quand rue il ya six mois et
aujourd'hui on n'a pas fait grand chose
rien fait que donc on devrait en faire
les gens parce que sam des choses n'ont
pas été faites alors avant de revenir
justement sur les conséquences l'impact
électoral que ça peut avoir ça c'est
peut-être quelque chose qu'on peut
aborder en deuxième partie il y a alors
là que l'autre question la seule
composante ou les cas aujourd'hui sur le
site de figaro elle concerne sur les
écoles est ce qu'il faut les garder
ouvertes en cas de confinement on a
passé le cap des 70 mille votants juste
avant le début de cette émission vous
étiez une majorité oui à répondre 73 %
répondent oui qu'il fallait garder les
écoles ouvertes
denis olivennes va plus loin dans un
tweet il demande je cite à ce que les
lieux culturels théâtres musées
librairies soient considérés comme de
première nécessité au même titre que les
commerces alimentaires bref à les
laisser ouverts est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça philippe alors je vais
beaucoup au théâtre et je vois bien que
je n'ai pas vu de théâtre aucun dans
lequel les gestes barrière c'est à dire
le distance entre deux personnes de
groupes de personnes le port du masque
ne soient pas respectés ni dans le
personnel bien sûr ni parmi les
spectateurs du coup j'ai évidemment du
mal à imaginer que ses théâtres ses
opéras ou cet opéra-comique puisse être
un foyer de l'infection
de surcroît on a répété à juste titre
que le monde du spectacle était
économiquement aujourd'hui plus
important que le monde de l'automobile
il emploie davantage de gens ils
emploient davantage de gens qui sont
dans des situations extrêmement
différentes financièrement drac
l'arrêté de stars et des mesures qui ont
été prises financièrement pour prolonger
les droits des intermittents d'un an à
peu près en somme le dos d'accord mais
vous ne faites pas du théâtre pas plus
que vous ne faites un métier que vous
avez choisi des gens qui malheureusement
font un métier qui n'ont pas pu choisir
mais quand vous faites un métier que
vous avez choisi vous ne me faites pas
seulement pour le salaire si on nous
mettait tous chez nous on nous disait en
coûter votre salaire vous fait pas et
vous allez avoir 80% de votre salaire
restez chez vous le dire bien entendu on
serait content d'avoir 80 % de notre
salaire pour se nourrir nourrir les
l'ordre etc
mais enfin l'idée de rester pendant des
mois sans avoir aucune espèce d'activité
correspondant à celles qu'on fait
d'habitude c'est extrêmement lourd de
surcroît il ya quand même dans le fait
d'aller au spectacle
le peu de sociabilité que nous avons
actuellement c'est une sociabilité que
nous avons je dirais même pas au cinéma
un peu au cinéma mais encore plus au
théâtre bien sûr parce que au théâtre il
ya une réaction collective qui se
manifeste et à laquelle on prend part ou
pas par selon prendre apprécié au cours
d'un principe à la pièce mais voilà je
pense que ce oui c'est un c'est une
question à laquelle il faut réfléchir et
plaintif que d'accord explique le second
c'est que ça colle pas avec le
confinement il réussit on confine donc
on peut pas laisser les incendies on
dira de vous personne ne sort mais vous
avez parce que précisément pour des
raisons de surveillance c'est clairement
dit personne ne sort si si il faut
arrêter toutes les voitures en disant
alors tout le temps tu as ton billet de
théâtre d'ailleurs je vais au théâtre
mais je vais prendre mon billet enfin
briller je pense que c'est nouveau le
vrai franck les librairies c'est un peu
différent dans mon souvenir lors du
premier confinement les librairies
n'étaient pas tenus de fermer
malheureusement il n'avait pas voulu
ouvrir
donc la profession
l'interprofessionnelle avait choisi de
rester ferme et j'espère que là il y en
aura il en ira différemment leur même
des spectacles dans la sphère compliqué
parce que ça allait au théâtre à 19
heures il ya comme avant 19 heures à 17
heures pour en sortir c'est le cas déjà
un mois je suis allé au théâtre de choix
sur 3 à trois heures de l'après-midi oui
mais où aller retour on a quand même
beaucoup de monde ouvert mais on y va
non mais on y va on est ici à
confinement confinement de 0,20 à 23h59
donc dernier point sur la question qu'on
pose aujourd'hui sur le site du figaro
donc sur les écoles faut les laisser
ouverte il ya deux mois j'aurais
tendance à dire oui après il ya plein
autant de réponses que de deux points de
vue comment dire presque professionnel
les médecins vous vous dire mousse que
les enfants son poids contagion n'est
pas tout à fait sûr qu'ils ne soient pas
en vérité on a dû une fois que tu
n'étais pas très puis pas du tout puis
en fait si beaucoup puis maintenant on
dit ou ce pas trop tout cas c'est ce que
reconnaît le dr pierre ricaud et non
médicales doivent en revanche nul et les
l'élection qui s'intéressent à
l'éducation et à leurs enfants dit c'est
un désastre de laisser quasiment deux
années de suite des enfants sans école
moment on apprend à lire et c'est
comment on fait pincer c'est comme très
compliqué et j'ajouterai que les
salariés ou les chefs d'entreprises
disent si on garde les petits chez soi
on fait pas du télétravail avec des
enfants dans les pattes ça n'existe pas
donc ça fait quand même pas mal de
raisons de 2
d'ouvrir les écoles avec un risque oui
il y aura risquerait oui enfin on parle
des élèves et on a raison mais les
enseignants vous sont aussi un sujet de
préoccupation et centrait sujet de
préoccupation parce que ils ont le droit
de savoir dans quelles conditions ils
vont pouvoir exercer la mission qu'on
leur confie
et je dirais qu'en ce moment après
l'assassinât de conflans sainte honorine
ce qui est remonté en masse de la
société enseignante si je puis dire la
population enseignante
c'est je cherche j'essaye d'avoir des
mots un peu pas trop dur mais c'est
celle eu la conviction d'être délaissée
et que par conséquent l'idée qu'on leur
dise vrai coup de maintenant falloir
retourner au charbon
tu pas sûr que ça les enchantés que
leurs organisations professionnelles
prennent ça est ce qu'on appelle un
autre point sur l'histoire justement des
écoles c'est que d'un côté on a des
organisations professionnelles des
organisations syndicales qui elles sont
plutôt favorables a enfin un confinement
à ce que les écoles restent fermées
plutôt des parents d'élèves qui eux
veulent mais c'est sûr c'est sûr que en
tout cas le côté parents d'élèves s'il
ya aucun doute là dessus les gens
préfèrent que pour aller c'est la fin
utilisant comme ovi de travailler et
même contre leur dit de travailler chez
eux ils ont envie de travailler et donc
c'est pas en gardant des enfants qu'on
arrive à demain on parle des petits
après midi les enfants sont grands eux
plus on peut enfin il ya là les
questions du télétravail selon la veuve
ce plus facile maintenant encore que
quand on a deux trois enfants on n'a pas
non plus deux trois ordinateurs pour la
faire suivre découvre c'est pas si
simple que ça puis tous les profs ne s'y
mette pas encore ce que c'est vrai que
les pros font souvent des réticences qui
ne peut comprendre à venir en gros mais
ils ont aussi parfois des réticences ou
des mises à niveau techniques qui ont
pas été faites et les outils
numérique qui savent pas forcément non
plus s'en servir donc c'est quand même
compliqué oui et encore nous n'avons pas
abordé la situation des gens qui sont
dans des appartements surpeuplés
manon qui sont déjà dans les catégories
sociales qui ont le plus c'est ce que
dit daubresse c'est quand même
intéressant de voir qu'un au mess par la
voie d'injonction pas parole dit nous ne
recommandons pas le gouvernement et plus
comme que nous ne recommandons plus
confinement comme moyen principal de
lutter contre la pandémie
nous en appelons aux dirigeants ne le
fait qu'en dernier recours ne le fait
qu'en dernier recours et surtout utilisé
le confinement pour préparer la suite
pour vous refaire nos forces et il
recommençait à à dimensionner votre
système de santé pour pas propre à être
obligé de recommencer trois mois plus
tard parce que si l'on ne fait rien on
passera le confinement puis ça va tomber
c'est sûr si on se renferme tout le
monde s'arrête mais sauf que si on n'a
pas remis en place un vrai système de
test cette fois c'est pour ça que l'état
ziani indigènes et qui sont importants
si on n'a pas mis plus de deux places
dans l'est dans l'est
urgence des trucs trois 3 mois après la
fin de ce confinement qui va durer on
verra un mois et demi ça repartira tout
pareil les mêmes causes entraînent les
mêmes effets il ya une logique dans la
vie donc jusqu'au moment où il fera beau
que jusqu'au moment où y aura peut-être
un avec ça m'enfin pas non plus tous les
3 mois arrêté le la ville de l'est du
pays avec les dégâts quand même qu'ils
sont colossaux parce qu'on se prépare
pas donc il faut utiliser ce complément
pour se préparer
quand elle recommandait le confinement
le metz avait oublié de dire tout ce
qu'elle était en train de dire
maintenant sur ce qui vous fait des
efforts les équidés sur les inégalités
qui s'accroissait le confinement est un
truc terrible pour les catégories les
plus modestes c'est sûr que quand on a
une maison de campagne
bon c'est pas y'a pire comme on a accès
à la fibre pour l'un du travail pierre
affirme qu'il faut faire comme en asie
subir un confinement qui rendent les
masques obligatoire et mettre à
l'isolément les cas positifs en quatre
mois finalement pas grise allemand il
faut les il faut les repérer pour les
reprises et est il donc plutôt de jazz
unique le tmx quelque chose de nouveau
dont tout le monde y est entièrement
efficace pas à 100 % à 80 % à 85 %
hélas ces messieurs de l'auto naissante
à 10h26 et 85 ont fait pas mais il vaut
mieux 85 de jean contagieux qu'on isole
que 0% je comprends pas ces deux corées
d'autant que les tests actuels sont
moins fiables que 85 % d'un peu au
secours mais il ya débat pas sur wii via
les isles trop tard ils sont très
fiables mais trop tard et vaut mieux un
truc un peu moins fiables alors que très
fiable trop tard encadrent confinement
c'est très simple je ne le
respecteraient pas le dit ferati sur
youtube fait attention aux automobiles
renoncer à ma liberté non et babineau
préfère un confinement total maintenant
de quelques semaines à des deux mesures
demi mesure inefficace prolongeant la
crise dans le temps si tu dis qu'il n'a
pas confiance et souhaiterait que ses
enfants puissent faire l'école à
distance est pragma lui n'arriverait pas
à travailler durant le confinement à
cause de ses enfants à la maison il ne
souhaite pas que cette situation
recommence parlant c'est pas gagné seul
on est au coeur du problème les infos
les déclarations c'est à retrouver dans
le live texte qui est en dessous de ce
player ou bien
en vidéo dès qu'elles sortent jean
castex dans une dizaine de minutes
reçoit les responsables politiques avant
de recevoir les responsables syndicaux
ce soir on vous tient au courant faut-il
s'inquiéter en attendant du vote blanc
et protestataire c'est l'autre question
qu'on pose ce soir et composent cette
fois ci sur twitter hashtag plein de vue
et sur youtube derrière cette question
il ya des chiffres qui ont été données
par l'institut opinionway pour la
fondation paul à retrouver sur le site
du figaro dans un article notamment de
loris boischaut 79% des français sont
prêts à s'abstenir voter blanc ou voter
protestataires lors de la prochaine
élection
si on compare par rapport à 2010 est
c'est quasiment 20 points de plus à
l'époque c'était 60,9 déjà sur ce point
peut-être un premier commentaire une
première analyse alexis comment dire si
cette enquête elle met des chiffres sur
quelque chose qu'on sent qu'on pressent
qu'on voit d'ailleurs aux élections déjà
se produire d'élection en élection
l'espèce de fossé qui se creuse entre
les français et leurs dirigeants et s'il
ya mille mille exemples locaux vides en
est on en parlait à l'instant un un
moment supplémentaires mais il y avait
eu les gilet jaune ya vu la réforme de
retraites et je ne sais pas commun qu'on
s'adapte bien avant ces quelques va la
montée de l'abstention la montée du
rejet des partis politiques
quelque chose qu'on constate depuis très
longtemps ce qu'on voit là c'est que
certes ça profite en partie à marine le
pen à mélenchon que que que la fondapol
regroupe sous l'étiquette populiste mais
pas tant que ça a failli attendre de
progression que ça c'est surtout le
ras-le-bol en laisse tomber on n'ira pas
voter on s'en fout c'est tous pareils
comment dire avec le temps on a presque
le sentiment que marine le pen et
mélenchon soit assimilé au système il
progresse plus là c'est frappant alors
la fin quelqu'un finira quand même par
gagner mais mais c'est quand même
intéressant de voir qu'il ya pas c'est
pas l'un ou l'autre c'est c'est surtout
le côté j'irai pas voté je voterai blanc
je votais dieu j'en ai marre voilà alors
j'ai retenu une chose
enfin plusieurs mais une que je voudrais
mettre en avant et que ceux qui veulent
continuer à participer à la vie
politique à travers le vote sont les
plus vieux mais quand en dessous en
dessous de la tranche d'âge de 65 ans et
plus là pour le pousser on vote avec ses
pieds et ça c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui doit être pris très
sérieusement en considération
l'autre chose je ne crois pas que ce
soit une cause majeure mais ça a été une
cause importante les municipales le fait
d'avoir tenu le premier tour des
municipales dans les conditions dans
lesquelles on les a tenus puis le
deuxième tour quelques semaines plus
tard ont contribué à décrédibiliser le
vote est évidemment ceux qui sont élus
oublient aujourd'hui qu'ils ont été élus
avec un infime pourcentage des électeurs
inscrits et un petit pourcentage des
suffrages exprimés
ils sont élus ils s'accrochent à leurs
écharpes et il oublie complètement le
peu de gens qui ont contribué à leur
élection
ceux qui eux n'ont pas contribué à
l'élection ce qu'on sentiment qu'ils ont
été bernés dans cette affaire eux à mon
avis ils l'oublient pas et ont le
sentiment que déjà que la participation
vote est fragile qu'elle a été
ridiculisé par cette 16ème ce maintien
de la fin de l'élection président de
l'élection miss pearl au premier tour et
le report du deuxième tour au moins dieu
ensuite effectivement ce qui est
important à l'ex il a dit je vais pas
m'étendre dessus c'est l'augmentation de
l'abstention ou du vote blanc celle du
vote blanc est spectaculaire et le vote
blanc n'étant pas reconnue et ne
risquons pas l'être un syndication
justement que nous pose jean si on
reconnaît le vote blanc équidés
majoritaire que fait-on est ce que c'est
un bras les jambes isabelle blanc
saultain
il ya une autre alors il y a il ne
rentre
il ya une autre on sent bien qu'on a des
gens du midi de la france commence à
faire des blagues sur jacques blanc du
sommet aura des ambitions pour
impressionner tête organisé un débat
entre jacques blanc et michel noir alors
on pourra pas justement hélas le faire
mais en tous les cas on a cette
confidence quand vous livre il y as
parmi les bénéficiaires présumés même
s'ils sont moins nombreux et moins leur
épingle du jeu vous venez de le dire
alexis à marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon qui sont considérés dans
l'étude comme candidats protestataires
alors sur ce point je vous propose
d'écouter justement la réaction d'un
proche de jean luc mélenchon c'était
hier dans l'édition des missions que
l'on produit avec la chaîne
parlementaire et public sénat dans
audition publique la réaction d' alexis
corbière
moi je ne suis pas un candidat
protestataires même madame le pen elle a
un projet politique
c'est un peu facile de latéralisé la vie
politique en gros entre ceux qui
seraient les proposant et ceux qui se
réuniront protestataires en gros y
aurait des gens sérieux ceux qui
gouvernent et les protestataires qui
évidemment aucune proposition à faire
voyez que dans le choix des mots il ya
déjà une idéologie politique
je suis pas d accord ça mais je suis
rarement d'accord il patine bien sûr
mais c'est vrai c'est dire que le fait
de dire cela ils font que protéger non
ils n'ont pas encore montré qu'il est
très ciblé absurde ce programme on devra
l'être contre mais ils ont quand même un
programme ils ont souvent même d'un
programme plutôt plus clair que d'autres
partis par ailleurs dans les denrées
utilisant le programme je suis d'accord
mais pour essayer d'attirer l'attention
sur eux ils ont une tendance à utiliser
la protestations tous azimuts et après
oui il fait même des choses le sont ou
là mais celui d'abord vous arrive jamais
contre la progression ressort politique
voulait dire des protestaires c'est
sous-entendre c'est que les gens qui
votent pour eux ne savent même pas
pourquoi ils voient qu'ils votent parce
qu'ils sont pas contents ces petites
choses qui achèteraient vraiment qui
dirait on de mêmes que pour mon corps va
pas que pour mais c'est d'abord ça qu'on
voulait regarder le far-west heures je
tiens le médiator est appelé oui il
avait parlé je sais pas s'il faut filer
la métaphore mais regardons du côté d'un
marché de macron eux il y avait
évidemment une dimension protestataires
dont le vote a bénéficié macro on a
sorti les sortants votants macron ceux
qui ont voté macron ils protestaient
contre donc le côté protestataires ne
serait que les uns et que les autres
cantons
quand on vote pour l'opposition c'est
aussi qu'on proteste voilà c'est moi je
serai à la limite peu importe la
dialogue mais dans les chiffres de
dominique reynié la fondapol c'est pas
eux qui tient leur épingle du jeu c'est
pas marine le pen non plus ceux qui
tirent leur est pas une vanne un soc le
plus solide que les zouk mnl malraux ou
que jean luc mélenchon c'est ce qui
ressort
ll un vrai que plus solide mais grosso
modo la masse des gens qui se tournent
vers elle n'augmente pas de manière
spectaculaire
ce qui augmente c'est l'intérêt et
quelquefois même l'adhésion pour les
verts et ça c'est une curieuse question
parce que qu'est-ce qui dans les
comportements des verts en dehors du
fait qu'ils ne sont pas pour le moment
un dans le pays son nouveau dhaouadi son
nouveau voilà est-ce que c'est la seule
chose est ce que c'est le le triomphe de
la nouveauté
j'avais dit relativise quand même la
portée du vote vert non il relativisé la
portée de la gagner il a décidé une fois
pour toutes que les verts n'avaient pas
gagné les municipales il le prouvera
jusqu'au bout
le problème c'est que ce sondage montre
que l'os peut-être ils n'ont pas gagné
les municipales et ils veulent la
détient mais enfin quand même dans les
effectifs mans dans l'est dans les
souhaits de vote et dans les diverses en
train de monter de façon très forte et
au delà de dépopulation des grandes
villes concernées uniquement par pas des
sept grandes villes puisque dominique
dit toujours est il que cette grande
ville on casse les pieds c'est pas du
tout une vague bon d'accord mais son
sondage montre que quand même salaire ça
progresse quand même pas si mal pour
venir marine le pen moi ce qui me frappe
c'est que reste stable qu'un stuff soit
que faure impuissant mais mais
s'étonnant qu'elle progresse pas
davantage quand on voit l'évolution des
préoccupations des gens c'est quand on
voit que par exemple la délinquance dans
les dom dans l'est dans les priorités
fixées par les sondés a fait un bond
colossal est passé de 30 à 50 % entre
janvier et septembre
hélas l'islam évidemment le sondage
avait été fait avant le l'horrible
attentat conseil mais je suppose que la
coupe sur l'islam est la même tous les
thèmes qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
ascendant est très fortement ascendants
sont des thèmes qui doivent assurer
qu'il devrait profiter marine le pen est
donc
l'ips alors il ya deux hypothèses la
presse d'hier n'est pas bonne on y
arrive pas et c est sans doute en tout
cas le souvenir de son premier débat et
l'autre hypothèse c'est de dire que
finalement elle est depuis si longtemps
dans le paysage qu'elles ne bénéficient
pas de ce pro de vote protestaires elle
finit par dans le système et que donc
les électeurs la regarde comme un
élément constitutif d'un système qu'il
rejette globalement c'est quand même
quand on regarde la télévision les
télévisions qu'on voit apparaître
marine le pen est un les gens du front
national qui sont répartis sur
l'ensemble des chaînes d'information
continue ou bien sûr l'ensemble des des
grandes chaînes
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
l'élément de surprise joue rarement et
que neuf fois sur dix je pourrais dire
ce que ce que va dire la personne ces
guérillas pour eux parce qu'ils peuvent
voir marine le pen c'est la chercher
justement ça à faire partie des meubles
pour pouvoir se faire pour pouvoir sont
comme on disait en tout cas ce
respectabiliser mais je vois par exemple
les questions qui sont liées à la
délinquance
quel est le contenu la réponse de les
gens du front national plus de flics
plus de prisons plus de sévérité
mais les gens voient bien que ça marche
pas comme ça et que donc à faire il voit
pas qu'il voyait que ça marche pas il
n'y a pas fait bien longtemps qu'il ya
pas vraiment plus de flics plus de
prison c'est tout le monde promet d'en
faire puis en effet jamais et plus de
sévérité
chacun voit que l'application de lois
pénales qui sont globalement pas papa si
la crise que ça que l'application des
lois pénales est de moins en moins
sévère donc on peut pas dire que les
gens voient que ça marche pas les gens
disent il faudrait le faire
non je dirais pas ça mais effectivement
on va formulation n'était sans doute pas
très adroite ce coup en hameau près pas
très adroit
enfin très à droite non plus donc ça ne
marche pas vous faites pas déprimant
comme ça vous fait pas dix mille
policiers comme ça vous ne faites pas
vous ne pouvez pas continuer à utiliser
un système pénal qui ne prévoit pas ou
ne donne pas à ce qu'ils prévoient les
moyens que ça marche oui les système de
bracelet électronique les systèmes de
travaux d'utilité publique les systèmes
tout ce qui fait un certain nombre une
chaîne j'allais dire pédagogique de
peine tout ça est fait c'est vrai que
c'est là dépend de la bonne volonté mais
des magistrats et du personnel
judiciaire bien plus ça dépend aussi des
choix des choix budgétaires
bah oui mais macron s'y était engagé
tendance sm encore des dvd on va
construire en cause elle présentait
finalement il ne le fait pas et donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand il n'y a plus
place de prison fait sortir les gens
parce que aujourd'hui l'application des
lois pénales je pense pas que ce soit
une une volonté perverse de la part des
magistrats simple il n'y a plus de place
en prison et on se dit plutôt que de
tout d'engorger engagé prison on va les
faire sortir plus tôt mais ce n'est pas
une méthode d'adapter les peines aux
prisons il vaudrait mieux pas et adapter
les prisons il ya une augmentation de
budget de la justice qui est
suffisamment remarquable pour qu'on
puisse espérer qu'il se passe quelque
chose alors qu'ils se passe quelque
chose à un niveau tout bête parce que là
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles
des décisions justice ne sont pas
appliquées ou sont appliquées trop tard
à un moment où une signification c'est
parce que les greffes sont en fait
mander mais ça c est que grâce à dieu on
continue à respecter le formalisme qui
fait que un jugement qui a pas été
signifié sa part un jugement
ça n'existe pas c'est ça qui est
formidable philippe avec vous dès qu'on
a lancé un autre débat ont créé un autre
débat alors maintenant on est tombé sur
un débat sur la sur la justice et c'est
pour ça qu'on ne cesse de recommander le
nouvel esprit public qui a podcast ou
d'abord tous les tous les thèmes favoris
récemment abordé la juste la question à
70 donc le nouvel esprit public.fr le 79
% des électeurs envisage un vote anti
système en 2022 faut-il s'en inquiéter
ça c'est une question qu'on posait sur
twitter et sur youtube et bien c'est la
parité dans la réponse c'est 50% chacun
donc on n'arrive pas à vous
départager le vote blanc ou l'abstention
sur le résultat d'une absence d'offre
politique crédible estime markus guy
axel
moi je pense qu'on doit voter pour des
idées j'en ai marre de voter pour des
partis qui n'en n'ont que faire de leurs
électeurs et jean-marc nous dit quand un
système est mauvais mauvais il faut en
changer et c'est bien le cas ici sauf
que jean-marc ne dit pas par quel
système le changer et marcuse dit encore
qu'il nous dit marine le pen est une un
obstacle à nul autre que marine le pen
n'est plus cohérente depuis qu'elle ne
veut plus sortir de l'union européenne
ça doit être assez kafka est très
passionné encore l'autorité qu'il
faudrait une idée en comme ça faisant
des variations des arabesques sur les
chiffres de la fondapol et dominique
reynié peut-être sutil a ajouté qu' on
n'a encore pas tout vu c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas vu encore les conséquences
sur l'offre politique à l'extrême droite
de l'attraction de l'extrême droite sur
le corps électoral
je veux dire par là que marine le pen
elle va forcément avoir à faire à des
concurrents à l'intérieur de cette
propre famille politique et que là les
choses électoralement parlant se
présentent autrement on voit déjà le
maire de béziers qui a commencé une
offensive pour laquelle il est assez
bien outillé quand on est là que tout la
participation et le taux lequel il a été
élu et on en aura d'autres donc là
encore c'est comment dire les craintes
doivent être tempérés par la pente
naturelle des mouvements quand ils ont
le vent en poupe à produire un nombre de
candidats c'est-à-dire de concurrents et
maintenant on n'a pas vu non plus les
conséquences de cette affaire du coc
vide les conséquences électorales et
notamment sur sur même pas où l'on
municipal je crois pas non non je crois
vraiment faim le municipal c'était
précisément les gens étaient
déboussolées enfin ils ont essayé
d'appliquer mais à la présidentielle
difficile de penser que que la sphère du
comité sera pas le sujet majeur a
presque inconscient chez les gens ce
sera pas le débat fin peut espérer qu'on
en sera sorti de mes mots mais mais
cette période aura tellement marqué les
esprits que les gens peuvent se dire
finalement l arrivée sur pas si mal
débrouillé que ça après tout où pourra
se dire ils ont été nuls ou bien se dire
ils ont peut-être pas été si mauvais
mais pour moi c'est des mauvais
souvenirs fourre tout ça sans ail et à
mon avis le vrai risque aujourd'hui pour
macron c'est d'être associés à des
années qu'ils sont des années de malheur
il y peut rien mais c'est comme ça il va
on verra ça peut-être qu'on aura un
autre test cette fois ci c'est aux états
est viré après après 1945 passé on verra
tout le bruit
on verra peut-être sa ba lors d'un
prochain scrutin mais qui n'est pas en
france mais qui est aux états unis la
semaine prochaine sur l'impact justement
de cette crise et de cette geste de sa
gestion dans les résultats des élections
si on a des résultats mardi et mercredi
prochains merci beaucoup d'ici là on se
retrouvera pour point de vue demain vous
allez rendez vous vous retrouvez
guillaume roquette et on se retrouve dès
9h30 demain pour le boss tv
[Musique]